A three story building is about 10 meters tall,
six times bigger than you. In the opposite
direction, six times smaller than you,
you get things like a cute squirrel about 27
centimetres small. So the building is just as
big relative to you as you are to a squirrel.
You're in the middle. It's easy to understand.
In fact, you are in the middle of everything
in the Universe. Let's go on a fantastical
journey together, to the small and the
large and see if it's really true!
An A320 is 37 meters long. TheRufous
hummingbird is around 7 centimetres.
Both of these fliers are23 times
bigger or smaller than you,
and both fly intercontinental distances - the
tiny bird migrates between Alaska and Mexico!
If the hummingbird were the same size as the jet,
it would circle the Earth 85 times every year!
Dinoponera, the largest ant in the world,
is about55 times smaller than you.
Their small colonieshave around 100 individuals but no queens –instead they ruthlessly compete for status
within the nest, which can reach 1.2 meters deep.
If humans lived like Dinoponera, we’d be building
towers of over 25 stories filled with offices
and ruthlessly competing for status and...wait…
The deadliest and most annoying insect in the
world is the mosquito, 235 times smaller than you,
while on the other end the Empire state building
is about that much larger than you. Kind of
unimaginable how something this small creates
so much devastation for something that big.
We are getting to the borders
of human perception now.
Like coarse grains of sand about 3
millimeters, 550 times smaller than you.
You can feel their shape and roughness
between your fingers and if you focus,
see them individually. We mix them into concrete
that can hold up the tallest towers ever built,
like the 828 meter tall Burj Khalifa that is 500
times larger than you. If you were that tall,
people would be as small to you as grains
of sand in your hand. Hey! Be gentle.
Anything smaller or bigger
and it becomes hard to grasp.
A medium sized city like Lisbon
is about 6000 times larger than
yourself and permeated by a network
of highways, roads and alleys.
On the other end, about 6000 times smaller
than you, are your small arteries permeating
your whole body. Actually you are in the middle
between your network of blood vessels and the
network of a city like Lisbon. If you think of
a city as a living being, you find more and more
parallels. A small alley is as small to the city
as an arteriole 0.1 millimeters wide is to you.
Your tiniest capillaries are to you, what the
pipes bringing water to homes are to Lisbon.
Going further, 100,000 times smaller than
you, we reach a typical skin cell about 30
micrometers in diameter, a Neutrophil is half as
big and one of your red blood cells is merely 7
micrometers. They are as small to you, as you
are to the entire Tokyo Metropolitan Area,
the largest urban area in the world spanning
over 160 km. You are so incredibly big,
filled with so much complexity, so many
different moving parts. Or are you just a
cell, in the human civilization
superstructure? Are you both?
Our steps are getting larger and larger now.
Germany is around 875 km from North to South
and the 4th biggest agricultural exporter in the
world. Rhizobia is a nitrogen-fixing bacteria up
to 3 micrometers long and without it, that sort of
agricultural production is impossible. So we have
a country and a bacterium depending on each other,
and you are in the middle, both being roughly
550,000 times larger or smaller than you.
What about the whole Earth? It’s
about 12,700 km in diameter;
about 7.7 million times larger than you. On
the other side of the scale is Corynebacterium,
as little as 0.3 micrometers across, living
on your skin and eyes along with 100 billion
other bacteria. More than ten times
more than there are humans on earth.
Again you are in the center. Right
in the middle of something so large
that our civilization is a mere scratch on its
surface, and something so small and numerous you
never notice its presence even as it touches
you. Does that make you feel small, or big?
From here on out, your brain is breaking a bit.
4 times wider than Earth is Neptune, a
cold blue gas giant 49,500 km wide. The
largest planet though is Jupiter, 140,000
km in diameter. A titanic abyss shrouded
in terrible winds. You could drop Earth whole
into its depths and it would simply vanish.
On the opposite scale we find
the deadly West Nile virus,
50 nanometers in diameter. Or one step down,
the spike proteins on a coronavirus, that open
up cells for its RNA payload – they are as small
to you as you are to the planet Jupiter. You are
in the middle between gigantic planets and the
world of viruses. These tiny things. So deadly.
Let that sink in – a tiny virus is
taking over and killing lung cells
up to 500 times larger than itself, with
the help of a tiny protein weapon. That is
like you trying to kill a giant the size
of the Burj Khalifa with a screwdriver.
But the real boss of the Solar System is the Sun.
Ten times bigger than Jupiter, a billion times
larger than you, controlling all the planets
and source of all energy that drives life.
A billion times smaller than you, clearly
the boss of our body is a DNA strand,
containing all the information making
your life possible. You’re right in the
middle between the most important
factors keeping everything alive.
From here on on things just
kind of stop making sense.
A billion is already too much but now
everything just seems to mean ‘a lot’.
The supermassive black hole at the
center of our galaxy, Sagittarius A*,
is 14.5 billion times bigger than you.
A hydrogen atom is 15.5 billion times
smaller than you. Yeah ok sure. But the
thing is, we are not even close to being
done and it's not impossible to get
at least a sense of how these scale.
The solar system is 22 trillion times larger
than you – On the other end of the scale is the
wavelength of low energy neutrinos released
from fusion reactions in our Sun – about
a hundred trillion of them are passing through
you every single second, like ghosts a trillion
times smaller than you, basically never hitting
any of the particles inside you. If you moved
through the solar system in a straight line
you probably wouldn't hit anything either.
Although things are beginning
to get really weird now.
A single proton at the heart of the
hydrogen atom is almost exactly 1
quadrillion times smaller than you.
If the proton were as big as you,
the hydrogen atoms would be
taller than twelve Mt. Everests.
On the other end, we meet something that
just breaks human brains: the incredible
vastness of space, we just have no reference
for these distances at all. The distance to
the closest star to earth, Alpha Centauri, is
not 1 quadrillion times in the other direction
from the tiny proton – but 24 quadrillion.
Space is just so large it is kind of mean.
And it goes on like this.
A quintillion times smaller than you is the
strange world of the quarks. The proton is
not actually like a tiny ball but kind of
just a ripple on the surface of the ocean
of quarks. Every moment, countless quarks pop into
existence, along with their anti-particle enemies,
before doing furious battle and annihilating each
other in an instant. How many? Impossible to say,
because the harder you look for them
the more quarks seem to appear. We’re
simplifying so much it’s like a lie anyway.
However we choose to illustrate this,
it's wrong. What actually is a quark, what
does it look like to human minds? Nobody knows.
As you sit here, confused, let’s look up
again. The ocean of quarks in a proton,
inside a single atom of a single
cell of your body is as small to you,
as you are compared to a sphere around 174 light
years across, containing about 16 thousand stars.
And this is just a tiny speck of dust
to our galaxy. The Milky Way is close
to one sextillion times larger
than you. At the opposite end,
we have particles a sextillion
times smaller than yourself;
like the wavelength of high energy neutrinos
released when cosmic rays hit our atmosphere.
We are getting to the end.
The Observable Universe is 93 billion lightyears
in diameter. Close to a billion billion billion
human lengths. But it’s still finite. It’s
‘only’ 465,000 Milky Ways side by side. If
you were the size of our galaxy, the observable
Universe would only be a day’s drive across.
On the other end of that scale, we have
the tiniest particle ever detected,
a proton travelling so close to the
speed of light it got squished into a
pancake. As small compared to you as the
whole Observable Universe is big to you.
We are at the border of things that we have
evidence for – are you truly in the middle
of everything? The theoretical smallest
physical distance is the Planck length,
a hundred million times smaller than even the
pancake proton. But we don’t know if it's real,
only that our theories of the universe
break down here. Likewise on the other end,
does the bigness of the universe match
the smallness of the Planck length? Well,
actually the universe could be considerably
larger than that. But we will never know.
Let’s go back and look at the dimensions again.
There are so many big things and so
many small things wrapped up in them.
The universe seems to be exactly the
right size – with you in the middle.
How do you try to get it exactly right,
say when you have to make a big choice
like buying a new mattress? You probably
compare trustworthy reviews and test out
a few models. But what if you plan to spend
money on something you can’t just return to
the seller – and the decision doesn’t
just affect your aching back? GiveWell
is an independent and rigorous resource for
a different kind of purchase: a donation.
GiveWells mission is to let donors make
informed decisions about high-impact
giving. That’s why they have now spent over 15
years researching charitable organizations and
only direct funding to a few of the
highest-impact opportunities they’ve
found in global health and poverty
alleviation – and why we trust their
judgment. You can find all of their research
and recommendations on their site for free.
Over 100,000 donors have used GiveWell to donate
more than one billion dollars. These
donations have the potential to save
over one hundred fifty thousand lives
and improve the lives of millions more.
If you’ve never donated through GiveWell
before, you can have your donation matched
up to one hundred dollars before the
end of the year or as long as matching
funds last. Donations made through them are
tax-deductible and GiveWell doesn’t take a cut.
To claim your match, go to givewell.org,
pick YouTube and enter KURZGESAGT at
checkout to get your donation matched.
Thanks to all of you out there.
For all the love and support!
We wish you a peaceful
and cozy turn of the year.
See you back at full throttle in January!